Voiceover:What I want to do in this video
is hopefully give more intuition
as to why the binomial theorem
or the binomial formula
involves combinatorics.
Let's just think about what
this expansion would be.
I'm just using a particular example
that's pretty simple,
x plus y to the third power
which is x plus y, times
x plus y, times x plus y.
We already know what the terms look like,
we could pick an x from each of these.
If we pick exactly an x from each of these
that's going to be our
x to the third term,
and we essentially picked no y [zen]
because we picked an x from each of this
when we multiplied out to get this term.
How many ways are there to construct that?
How many ways are there,
if we're picking from three things.
We're picking from three things,
how many ways can we
choose exactly zero y's
of not picking a y?
There's only one way to do that,
there's only one possible
way of doing that.
By not picking a y from each of them
or you can say by picking
an x from each of them.
The coefficient right over here
is one x to the third.
There's only one way,
when you take this product out,
only one of the terms
initially is going to have
an x to the third in it.
Now, what about the next term?
So plus.
Now we're going to pick from three buckets
but we want to pick one y.
Another way of thinking about it
you have three people
or we have three people,
this person, this person, and this person.
One of them you're going to choose to be
I guess be your friend
that's another way of
saying which of these
are you going to pick the y from?
This is the exact same thing
as a combinatorics problem,
from three things
you are choosing one of them to be y.
Of course three choose one,
this is equal to three.
If you're picking one y
that means you're picking two x's,
and you're taking the
product of everything
so it's x squared times y to the one
and we could keep doing
that logic, so plus.
Now we're going to think
about the situation
where we are picking two
y's out of three things.
It's x to the first, y squared.
We're starting with three things
and we're going to pick
two to two of this y's
so it could be this y and this y
to construct the product y.
It could be y times y times that x
or it could be y times y, times that x
or it could be y times x, times y.
This is three choose two,
out of three things what
are the different ways,
what are the combinations
of picking two things.
If you have three friends
how many combinations
can you put two of them
in your two seater car
where you don't care
about who sits in which seat.
You're just thinking about
how many different combinations
can you pick from that
and once again this evaluates to three
and then finally, how many different ways
from a set of three things,
from three different things,
so from each of these expressions,
how many ways can you
pick exactly three y's?
Well there's only one way to do it,
you pick this y, this y and that y.
If you're picking three y's
that means you picked zero x's
and you have picked three y's.
That's why we're dealing
with combinatorics here.
Three choose three.
From three expressions,
your three binomials, right over here
that you are taking the product from
you need to choose three y's,
so you have to pick the
second term in all of them.
There's only one way to do that,
here you want to pick the
second term, the y term,
in two of them, exactly two of them.
Here you want to pick the y term
in exactly one of them,
there's one way to do this,
three ways to do this,
so there's three ways to do this,
one way to do that,
one way to do that.
This is one,
this is three,
when you evaluate, when
you apply the formula
for three choose and choose k,
three and this is one.